à l'opposé d'une boîte de pandore
l'espoir désormais condensé dans une
petite fiole les résidents âgés d'une
maison de son à rome dans la temps de
recevoir un vaccin si longtemps désirée
je suis un peu nerveux mais une fois que
vous avez fait le vaccin
vous vous sentez libre et les choses
semblent positives pour la fois comme un
soulagement également pour gerardo
pensionnaires de cette structure depuis
le 4 mars 2020 de l'autre côté des alpes
le troisième âge durement touchés selon
l'institut supérieur de la santé
l'âge moyen des personnes décédées et
testée positive au qu'ovide 19 au pic de
l'épidémie
dépassés les 79 ans le gouvernement
transalpin cette issue aujourd'hui de
pouvoir présenter un remède miracle
il s'agit clairement du premier pas sur
un chemin qui n'est pas cours un chemin
qui nécessite encore de nombreuses
semaines de travail acharné pour que le
vaccin soit administrée à un grand
nombre de personnes
nous devrons encore résisté pendant les
semaines à venir et nous battre en
utilisant les instruments que nous avons
obtenu une compagne de vaccination qui a
débuté le 27 décembre dernier avec une
primauté donnée à cinq médecins et
infirmières d'un hôpital romain
spécialisé dans les maladies
infectieuses personnels de santé
personnes âgées puis viendront les
enseignants policiers et gardiens de
prison le vaccin
érigé au rang de devoir national par le
pouvoir
match et n'a fait elle achète à se faire
vacciner et à choix de responsabilité un
devoir
d'autant plus pour ceux qui travaillent
au contact des malades et des personnes
les plus fragiles face à une maladie
contagieuse qui provoque tant de décès
il est nécessaire de protéger sa propre
santé et il est de son devoir de
protéger celle des autres membres de la
famille amis et collègues collègues
si dans les prochains mois à la campagne
ne devait pas atteindre les deux tiers
de la population
alors nous devrions prendre des mesures
parmi celles ci il y aura l'obligation
mais la question ne se pose pas
aujourd'hui
le terme d'obligation qui fait grincer
des dents du côté de l'opposition
je suis pour l'éducation mais je suis
contre l'obligation
il est juste que les médecins expliquent
informe mais je n'aime pas les
contraintes
je suis convaincu que la seule façon de
faire une campagne sérieuse et
d'informer correctement les gens sans
hystérie ni parade d'aucune sorte
le gouvernement italien a passé commande
auprès de six laboratoire avec la
possibilité de pouvoir vacciner jusqu'à
13 millions de personnes
dès le 1er avril